[Music]  English lessons today's mini English  lesson is about minimal purse what's our  minimum purse minimal purse per words  the very height single sound the very  important for tuition so first example  we're going to look at is it all  together in second sound e now we know  this this sound that we have two dots  that means that the sound is longer  for example sits on the seats sits on  the seat now if you get it wrong it  would sound C on the seeds you get the  nouns and the verbs mixed up  nobody knows what's happening  everybody's confused sits on the seat  number two a like it's a lien a so a for  example wait  it's wet again you got this mixed up  what it's weights it's a lot of  confusion third example oh oh oh oh  for example so you saw the film all  together so you saw the film if you get  this wrong so you saw the film  we have the first one sits on the seats  wait it's wet so you saw the film these  are three examples of minimal purse  enjoy and practice  [Music]